um what intervals about when we started
the topic of integrals what did we say
integration was for it was for area
wasn't it now the funny thing about area
and trig functions right is that the
symmetry of all the trig functions gives
you weird kinds of properties for these
cards integrals for instance this is
sign and you can tell me right now with
no calculations that the integral from
water to PI of sine is zero because you
have this and you have this right so the
kinds of questions you will get here I'm
not gonna give you an example cuz I
think you can make I just do there's one
right these come from symmetrical areas
now you'll get to clients you get the
kinds of cancer lap like this okay
alternatively you'll get the ones that
are princess let's do this because if i
asked you to integrate cons for what's
that again negative plan to all up to
apply onto okay i could say that that
integral there's matters of close x i
can make that equal to what would i make
it equal to x naught 2 pi on to couldn't
I now by the way unless you have a
really good perfect diagram there you'd
better explain that and justify that
because it's like where did this come
from right so you would say by symmetry
of areas alternatively you can say as
cosine is an even function because
that's symmetry merit so here are the
basic ones here the ways they'll try to
throw you off but really they all come
back to these guys once you simplify now
okay